given a matrix how do we find its
adjoint this is a two-by-two matrix a
and we need to find its adjoint this is
a new term and maybe slightly confusing
but it will be easy if you concentrate
well for the next two minutes to find
the adjoint we first need to find some
matrix what is this some matrix it will
be of the same order as the original
matrix so we need to find the four
elements here each element will be the
cofactor of the corresponding element
from the original matrix so here we will
have the cofactor of the one one at
element here we will have the cofactor
of the one 2's element and so on
once this matrix is done we need to find
its transpose and that will give us the
adjoint of a we find the cofactors first
and then find the transpose of this
matrix the first element is to what will
be its cofactor it will be negative 1
raised to 1 plus 1 multiplied by its
minor 1 and 1 are the row number and
column number of 2 what will be its
minor we exclude the row and the column
and find the determinant of what remains
that will be the minor the determinant
of 3 will be 3 so this would be
multiplied with 3 this is the cofactor
of 2 negative 1 raised to 2 is positive
1 and 1 multiplied with 3 will equal 3 3
is the cofactor of 2 next we find the
cofactors of 5 1 and 3 the element 5
lies in the 1 to earth position so we
multiply negative 1 raised to 1 plus 2
with its minor to find the minor of 5 we
exclude Row 1 and column 2 and find the
determinant of what remains the
determinant of 1 is 1 1 is the minor of
5 so we multiply this with 1 to get the
cofactor negative 1 times 1 will give us
negative 1
negative one is the cofactor of five now
pause the video and try to find the
cofactors of one and three we get the
cofactor of one as minus 5 and that of
three as two these are the four
cofactors we found now we could write
this matrix down three minus one minus
five and two we have to find the
transpose of this matrix so we mark a
slant line here this will be the adjoint
of a do you remember how to find the
transpose of a matrix yes they
interchange the rows and the columns the
first row will become the first column 3
minus 1 and the second row will become
the second column minus 5 - that's the
adjoint of matrix a find the cofactors
first and then find the transpose of the
resulting matrix we will understand a
few more examples in the next part of
the session
you